hello everybody
and take a few minutes while everybody
is coming in and getting their sound and
their videos all connected
so wonderful to see you all today
I just love Fridays
so welcome welcome from around the
United States so far
and oh nope we're pitting International
Dr Wallach
so I love seeing all these names of
familiar names
and know where they're at and joining us
from so clear across the United States
north south east west up into Canada
um
and I see somebody coming in from other
continents as well so we are super
excited to have you here with us on ask
doc live
my name is Becca dukes and I will be
your host for the next two hours while
we bring you empowering encouragement
that allows you to be your own authority
when it comes to health and help you
with the information that you need so
that you can do it yourself so
I just have to remind you that if you
were invited into this or to watch this
video this program or here on live with
us today make sure that you get back
with the person that you were invited by
they took the time
to share this information because one
they believe in it and two they really
do believe that you can benefit from the
information that you are receiving today
so I love all the faces all the names
that are coming up and joining us is
super super exciting
now this program is sponsored by askdoc
live and we do have a website where we
have all of our recordings from our past
interviews our past shows with Dr
Wallach and pharmacist Ben and today
we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics now for those of you who do
not know what epigenetics is
epigenetics is actually a science that
has proven the genetic theory to be
incorrect
and this is done through some amazing
research
that has proven also that what you put
in your environment what you put in your
body and
what you don't eliminate does affect the
way that your genes are expressed
so that I hope brings some good news to
a lot of people I know it did me because
I had so many different conditions that
I was told well there's nothing you can
do about it but take Pharmaceuticals the
rest of your life because it's genetic
and that's just the way it is well I'm
living proof that they were wrong and I
am very very thankful that I am able to
use my story to help others and use
their stories to help even more as we do
reach around the world
so the information and the content that
is shared on this program is to provide
educational information only on the
importance
of nutrition and supplementation
folks are Food Supplies around the world
are becoming even more mineral deficient
and if the minerals are not in the soil
that the food is grown in
it's not going to be in the food that we
eat
think about it a plant eaten by an
animal whether we eat just plants just
animals if the minerals aren't there
they're not there so we have to be
intentional in what we
supplement with which I think it it goes
beyond supplementation
it's what's essential for us to be able
to not just survive but actually Thrive
now the products discussed are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease and again this
information in this Zoom is for
informational purposes only if you are
pregnant nursing or taking medications
please consult your health care
professional before starting any
supplement program
now
my health care professional my doctor
is the good doctor that is joining us
today Dr Joel Wallach he has been
instrumental in suing the FDA with nine
victories now these victories have led
to the addition of vital nutrients and
two foods and allowing the distribution
of the information that we're sharing
here today and others around the world
that has been proven to be factual by
science as essential in the need to
fight and
basically help protect us against
disease
so we bring good news again genetic
theory
you don't have to worry about it folks
and he'd guide us
on this journey we are honored to have
one of
the Klaus Schwartz commerative medal
recipients from 2011.
who has also received a lifetime
achievement in natural medicine and
philanthropy from the United Nations in
2015.
and so many many more he I mean he
deserves much more than he's received
but the fact is he's here for the people
for the health of it not so much the
financial gain and he's proven that by
detaching himself from the company that
supplies the supplements that we offer
and mention in this program and he's
supported by the cells of his books that
you can find at
drjwalik.com now Dr Wallach
welcome to
askdoc live but before you say anything
I want to remind everybody that's on
with us
make sure that you have the chat turned
on
because our co-host Ruth Ellen Sanchez
Heather Bowen and Dr Judy Reynolds who
are on here with us today they will be
sharing important information
that you don't want to miss out on in
the chat
also if you have a question for Dr
Wallach in regards to your health or the
health of someone that you care about
make sure that you raise your virtual
hand go to the zoom menu click on
reactions and then find that raise hand
option because I will be going through
and calling on people in the order that
their hand is raised now we do have the
chat where you can put your questions in
the chat but I don't always get to the
chat and it goes by so quickly that I
might miss it and fortunately I have my
co-host to have my back and they do send
me text messages but we want to make
sure that we get your questions answered
here on live because that is what people
are going to be able to resonate with as
they hear the things that you are going
through and they're like wait I have
that I have that I better listen and
folks when I listened my life changed
for the better so again Dr Wallach
welcome to ask.line
well thank you Rebecca and thank you
team for
um being here again on this great
morning and we have so much to do and we
probably got a thousand years of work
ahead of us
so dig in okay and I do want to announce
we uh you know these new tools I've been
talking about for some time are starting
to come out
um one of them is immediately available
is dial MD for MERS named after that
great great mystery movie dial M for
Murder okay this is dial MD for murder
and
um it goes into dozens of diseases that
of course the medical system said was
genetic and autoimmune and
um
the number of fatalities and and so
forth from these is very high and it
turns out that um nothing of what they
said was correct and so these disease
we're talking about Alzheimer's disease
or heart disease how about pressure
diabetes obesity liver disease it's a
lung disease and so on and
um it's one of those birth defects
um and so Val MD for murder you need to
get that CD and get into everybody's
hands and then of course we have a three
CD set of called there's a new Bull in
town because we're actually going to
really stand up and and um compete with
Red Bull the sports drink which has been
around for 25 plus years
and it turned out you know I wasn't
really paying attention to it until
um our dear hero
um Bruce Lee died he died at age 32.
Bruce Lee who he was supposed to be and
he was considered in every country in
the world in every country in the world
they looked at Bruce Lee as a
um icon
of Fitness he was the fitness Guru in
every country in the world and he died
at 32 in 1973 and so I started doing
research on what he ate and what he
didn't eat what he supplemented with
what he didn't supplement with it turns
out
um he only supplemented one mineral
magnesium
his B vitamins came from brewers yeast
um and then let's see here
um he did take vitamin C
and then the rest of it he he had gluten
for breakfast lunch and dinner
okay hey gluten for breakfast lunch in
there and so he thought he could get
everything he needed from eating good
food
and he died at 32. and of course the
reason was which I got stimulated to do
this
uh he died in 1973 and they never said
really what he died from
but
just a couple of I don't know weeks ago
just weeks ago
experts came out medical history too and
said well we finally figured out what
Bruce Lee died from in 1973 he died from
drinking too much water right okay so as
I says nonsense so I went through and
found out that he was eating gluten with
every meal supplementing with only one
mineral magnesium and um
the rest he thought he could get from
his food and he paid the price now his
last three months of his life uh he
switched his diet from gluten gluten
gluten to fruit and vegetables and he he
changed too late and he didn't
supplement extra and he died at 32.
terrible terrible terrible waste and I
have pictures of him when he was 20. and
he was the guy I mean he was probably
one of the most fit human beings ever at
that point and then I have pictures of
him at 30
okay two years before he died and he
looks like he's a hundred years old
what happened in those few years well
when you're just eating
nothing and he consuming bad stuff is
that's going to be what happens okay now
um again this new CD well let's just go
to there's a new Bull in town there's
three CDs in that set dead athletes
don't lie uh the second CD is exercise
while someone patient suicide the third
CD in that set is what kills
billionaires and the average life
expectancy a billionaire is a 66.7 the
average life expectancy of professional
athletes who get paid to exercise and
take care of themselves and perform at
the highest level
um let's see here their life expectancy
is
um
56.7
huh I thought exercise is everything no
exercise is just a piece
nutrition is everything okay and so we
got to go those directions now
um you look at the records here uh life
expectancy quickly uh us
um emergency room doctors or life
expectancy is 58.7
in the Philippines which I was in on a
zoom last night okay of 71. USA's
um his life expectancy of 75. Australia
is 82.9 I was I was also in Australia
okay for for a zoom yesterday I want to
be on a zoom in Australia tonight
Australia's 82.9 New Zealand is 82.3
Japan is 84.7
and Canada is 84. China's 76 UK is 81.
South Africa is 63. Mexico is 77 Italy
is 83. no surprise at that okay let's
see here and then of course I have 21
best-selling books we got four books
coming out
uh four new books coming out
um one of which is authored
um by a couple of people including
uh Rebecca Dukes okay
okay and you know there's a little bit
of a team putting that book together it
should be out here pretty soon uh we're
very excited about that it's called the
Wallach Revolution so that that should
be very useful and then Hell's Kitchen
uh that goes through the transition of
um uh going from wood and coal is there
a fuel
and we were using the wood ash as a
source of minerals for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years to
electricity and no more wood ashes no
more coal ashes so everything when when
she say to hell that's why we called the
book Hell's Kitchen after the terrible
District in New York City where
everything bad happens immortalities if
I go study we looked at the longevity
cultures uh what it is they proactively
did what it is they proactively avoided
it's all in the book and there's a CD
that goes along with it dead doctors
that live course started this whole
thing and the CDs
um let's see here they're translated in
nine languages and we sold over seven uh
actually over 600 and something million
copies of CD okay now and of course now
we have this CD out now
um
let's see here uh
we're looking at dial MD from her after
that movie title valm for murder it will
blow your mind all the stuff and all the
disease all the modern diseases all the
research and universities and government
uh in that CD it'll blow your mind and
it'll show you how far off how far wrong
the medical system is okay that's why
dial MD for murder and then
um it's all in your head it's on your
head
um there's 37 different diseases in
the book in this in the CD okay and
Rebecca is one of the co uh authors on
the CD okay it's on your head and then
Doctors Don't Lie of course she's
holding that book up still which is good
um that goes all over the world as you
can imagine
but the thing you have to appreciate is
it's all in your head it has to do with
osteoporosis of the skull
I don't see a process of the skull my
favorite picture in the whole book
is this one two two human skulls the top
one is normal it's only a quarter of an
inch thick okay and the bottom one is an
inch and a half to two inches thick okay
the top one is normal no problems the
bottom one of course squeezing the 12
pairs of cranial nerves and squeezing
the spinal cord and that's what creates
the 37 different diseases it's like
crazy when you think about it this is
very quickly reversible okay this is
very quickly reversible and with the
proper diet and proper supplement
program and so very excited about that
and then we have a companion book and CD
and DVD set okay called
the truth about nutrition was actually
the research and the first printings of
this book in CD and DVD were paid for by
two very famous movie actors okay they
don't want their name out and so
um this goes along with it's all in your
head okay so get these things at 25 to
50 Health years your life save yourself
an Earnest amount of unnecessary misery
save yourself an enormous amount of
money and add 25 to 15 Health years your
life
okay can I say something about this book
Dr Wallach oh please which book so the
truth about nutrition the book and the
CD and the DVD okay I'm using this as
part of my homeschooling program and
nutrition and physical education
so for those of you who are doing
homeschooling or know somebody that is
this is a great collection I mean it's
not super thick so my my son is
um fifth grade almost I mean it's not
even halfway through the fifth grade
year and he's got half a one course to
do before he hits sixth grade and yeah
Dr Wallach has the CD and the book up
there as well but it's an easy read but
there is so much information that is
packed into this collection that I wish
I would have known as a kid it probably
would have saved me a lot of pain
discomfort and money
um in my adult life and trying to figure
out what was wrong with me
it's all right here so I highly
encourage the truth about nutrition and
again you can get all of these books a
Dr Wallach speaks of at d r j
wallick.com and that's wallic w a l l a
c h
and we're going to have that in the chat
as well so you can go ahead and find
that link open it up in another screen
if you're on live with us and then check
it out later so thank you Dr Wallach for
letting me interrupt you on that because
I absolutely love this collection
okay well thank you so much Rebecca and
thank you for making time on your
program available for us to be there
okay so what I want to do and some of
this you know you hear once a week or
once a month but it's worth over and
over and over because there's always new
people coming along and remind you to
share this information
uh the cost just to treat the symptoms
of these diseases none of these figures
are to prevent or cure them all these
costs are just to treat the symptoms
Alzheimer's disease is 305 billion
arthritis is 626.8 billion diabetes is
342 billion heart disease is 316.8
billion obesity this is just the United
States okay obesity is 260 billion
cancer is 190 to 208 billion uh have a
pressure is 131 billion Ms multiple
sclerosis is 85 billion asthma and kids
under the age of 10 is 80 billion that
was a surprise and kidney dialysis is 24
billion okay
now I do want to remind everybody that
when you look at doctors again don't
don't forget that new uh it's not
actually new but it's newly reprinted
um the the CD dial MD for murder a life
expectancy of
um professional athletes in America is
53-59 for an average of 56.7 that was
freaky because exercise is supposed to
be everything right and then when you
look at athletes under the age of 25 in
America alone each year 2000 die of
hypertrophic carbaptic heart disease
deficiency of a single mineral okay and
Dr Milan and I we've done you know over
um let's see 1200 autopsies uh on kids
in China under the age of 10 that have
died from this hypertrophic cardiometry
heart disease and that's where we got
the Klaus Schwartz award farm for that
one uh is due to a deficiency of a
single nutrient okay and course
by getting this by suing the FDA nine
times in federal court we beat him nine
times and we were able to get these
minerals put into baby formulas and we
eliminated cystic fibrosis one of the
most terrible birth defects supposed to
be genetic we eliminated Muscular
Dystrophy and Jerry Lewis took that
information to the monsters Association
they fired him and shut down the
Telethon
and what a terrible thing they did but
we got rid of most Jewish history and
then sediment death syndrome supposed to
be according to doctors the mothers
laying on the babies and suffocating
them we got rid of sediment death
syndrome SIDS okay and they were very
excited about that
sorry about that that's my emergency
telephone thing saying something
happened in the world
um and see here billionaires or average
lifespan of 66. this was freaky and then
of course emergency room doctors is 58.7
all right
then
um
don't forget we
are the new Bull in town and our rebound
has 75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino
acids in it
Red Bull has one mineral you heard me re
Red Bull has one mineral magnesium just
like Bruce Lee had had one mineral
magnesium so I think when they did Red
Bull they did that based on
um Bruce Lee's formula okay that didn't
work out and they have four
um vitamins and amino acids okay so
um we have 25 vitamins amino acids they
uh Red Bull has four we have 75 minerals
and Red Bull has one
okay and so there's a huge difference
and so that's why you see a big big
positive difference in what we do and
what they do
obesity and of course this is covered
very heavily obesity is covered very
heavily in uh dial MD for murder because
you know the medical doctors have it
terribly wrong OBC obesity is due to and
this goes into in great detail due to
deficiencies and minerals when we went
from
pulled and what is fuel and putting the
ashes into our Gardens and the plants
would suck up the minerals because the
ashes from wooden and and coal are like
um minerals and three or four percent
carbon okay so we went to electricity
um just shorted 20 years later 18 years
later there was about 50 new diseases
nobody ever heard of they're all just a
simple nutritional deficiency these
mineral deficiency is
it was crazy okay because when we went
to electricity we shut off our source of
nutritional minerals that we have been
using for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years okay and so part of
the program for us to
help people lose weight okay we're
talking about I deal with so many people
who are 300 pounds from about 400 pounds
500 pounds 600 pounds every month from
all over the world and we get them on
our program for weight loss but it's not
just something to deter your appetite
but it's something to
reduce your seeking to find nutrition
okay when you take these nutrients
suddenly now you don't have pica anymore
Pica is just craving people get when
they're merely deficient and you see it
in horses they
um and chew on this top rail of the
fence and the stall in the barn or on
the wagons okay and it's called
um tripping okay when human babies are
mentally efficient they chew on the crib
Rail and they call that cribbing okay
and so
um but when they're sitting at a table
with food instead of chewing on the rail
on the bed they'll just chew on more
food and so you know there's great
detail in this CD dial MD for murder
named after the movie dial him for
murder okay okay so the cause of the BC
we already discussed that okay diabetes
um we have 37.3 million cases of type 2
diabetes in America that's like
um 10 percent
10 percent of our population we have 332
million people
um
let's see here uh
in
our population uh 11.3 percent of the
population okay has Type 2 diabetes and
here's the one that freaked me out 96
million one-third just about one-third
of our population is a pre-diabetic
they're pre-diabetic pre-diabetes
is due to mineral deficiencies these
mineral deficiencies cause the Pica and
also they mess around with your cellular
metabolism and so that's why people get
diabetes
so when you get on our program the
healthy blood sugar pack or if you have
two or four or five other things you get
the healthy brain and heart pack and
throw in the sweeties
based on your body weight and don't cold
turkey off your medication what you do
is you
as your blood sugar begins to drop you
can slowly reduce your medication based
on the numbers usually within two to six
weeks you'll be off your type 2 diabetes
medication off the insulin off the
metformin all that kind of stuff
and so we're very very proud of that
arthritis is very simple uh nutritional
deficiency disease okay causes 626.8
billion dollars just to treat the
symptoms and then osteoporosis this is a
freaky one osteoporosis in America alone
it causes 2.3 trillion dollars a year
with a t 2.3 trillion dollars a year
just to treat the symptoms so when you
look at our annual cost of
arthritis and osteoposis is three
trillion dollars a year just to treat
the symptoms no wonder there's so many
orthopedic surgeons
they're attracted by oh
you got it
and then lastly before we go back to
Becca and start talking to uh her
questions
okay
um the common disease and how she
approaches the skull we already talked
about that uh and it's all in your head
okay uh squeezing cranial nerve number
one the loss of the census milk
squeezing cranial nerve number two uh
you get optic nerve atrophy and and so
you're getting squeezing of the optic
nerve the optic artery and optic vein
squeezing cranial nerve number three you
get ptosis of the eye so your pupil does
not respond to light it's cranial nerve
number four being squeeze you get double
vision cranial nerve number five
terrible facial headaches okay
trigeminal neuralgia cranial nerve
number six being squeeze you get double
vision uh cranial nerve number seven get
squeezed you get Bell's Palsy cruel
nerve number eight get tinnitus ringing
in the ears deafness Virgo balance
problems all these together are called
Meniere's disease a cranial nerve number
nine being squeezed you get lost so the
gag reflex and taste um cranial nerve
number 10 being squeezed you get atrial
fibrillation doctors want to anesthetize
you cut your open take your heart out
and do a thing where they take a hot
Branding Iron put it all over your heart
okay and it has a high step treatment
okay has the highest death rate
percentage of any medical treatment okay
so you don't want to get that treatment
okay what you want to do is you know
take the healthy brain and heart pack
take the MSM take the collagen peptides
and the
um uh let's see here the extra calcium
take the vitamin D3 and it all goes away
okay as you see here loss of trapezius
muscle functions you can't raise your
arms okay
um as crayon or 11 being squeezed
parallel number 12 is please you get
atrophy of the tongue swelling reflex is
difficult uh you lose your speech and so
when you're getting cranial nerve number
nine being squeezed and cradle nerve
number 12 being squeeze at the same time
guess what you cannot communicate okay
the spinal cord there's 17 different
diseases you get south of the skull
um when you get this and okay this is
this all these diseases south of the
skull caused by the skull squeezing the
spinal cord is called wallach's fibrosis
named after me Wallace fibrosis so with
all that said that's a lot of stuff
don't forget that new availability of
that CD
um that uh
dial MD for murder the information on
that will blow your mind it's a full
hour of data okay it will blow your mind
over to you Becca
well Dr Wallach this is my favorite page
or pages in The it's an all it's all in
your head book
I'm sorry I can only see a piece of it I
can't see the whole thing
oh you've got something on your screen
that shouldn't be there yeah
so when you when you can visualize
cranial nerves
and what they're affecting
it just makes so much sense
and then there's a summary here in this
chart
so for this spread right here alone it's
worth
getting this book and it's called it's
all in your head
by Dr Joel Wallach and you can find it
at
drjwalik.com you can get the
get the hard copy with the CD that he
and I did with it if you're into the
Kindle you can go to
askdoclive.com and we have a link to the
Kindle version of this book as well so
just want to make sure we get all of
those bases covered because with times
changing the way that people access
information changes and we are working
at staying on top of that making sure
that Dr wallach's research his work and
his legacy continues Beyond 200 years Dr
Wallach and if we go a thousand years I
think that's a little
that's that's success so we are making
history here Dr Wallach and I'm so
excited to be part of it because folks
many of the things that Dr Wallach
mentioned
I was affected by
and my symptoms actually started when I
was eight years old
and that was with migraines and somebody
had asked here in the chat
um what can you do for
somebody a gentleman with bad migraines
age 56 5'8 220 pounds
plus sinuses issues
so Dr Wallach let's just go ahead and
start with that we've got a gentleman
56.
five foot eight
220 pounds with sinus issues
and I'm gonna say something right now
and migraines
and migraines yes
so before finding Dr wallach's protocols
I had sinus infections with every change
of the season
every change every year without fail
and I have not had a single sinus
infection Dr Wallach in seven years
and it's fabulous
so
go ahead and tell us what you would
recommend because most of that is what I
did okay well thank you so much Becca
all right well again over 200 pounds
this guy needs to get rid of all the bad
food so he maximize absorption and
relieve inflammation no fried foods
we're talking about
um
in any way shape or form and then
absolutely no
uh let's see here uh no sugar no
carbonated drinks absolutely no oils no
cooking oils no salad dressings no again
no processed Meats no hot dogs no bacon
no ham no bologna salami pastrami
pepperoni jerky corn beef spam all
that's got to go no gluten no wheat no
Ryan oats and no buckwheat because a lot
of times on the label of Buckwheat to
products so say gluten-free and big
letters and everybody grabbed that and
started eating and they get sick in two
weeks what's going on well buckwheat
doesn't have gluten in it but it has a
substance called fago Pyrenees which are
worse than gluten so no wheat by Ryan
oats and no buckwheat okay and then
again no sugar and no carbon or drinks
the carbonation neutralizer stomach acid
so you cannot absorb minerals or digest
food
then we want you to
take a big 200 pound guy he needs two
healthy brain and heart pasture months
of photos everything twice a day it's
215 nutrients the core of which is still
the 90 essential nutrients and then
I want him to take uh let's see here two
bottles a month of our MSM so we take
three of breakfast sweet lunch for your
dinner time they're going to support the
immune system through the bone marrow
but also help rebuild cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrate bone makes
bone itself and then it needs to take
two canisters a month of the collagen
peptide so we take a scuba that with his
morning drink and a scuba that was an
evening drink it has collagen from fish
poultry sheep and beef and then we want
him also to have the Beyond Osteo
effects so he can take a scoop of that
with his breakfast drink and evening
drink don't forget vitamin D three three
of those twice a day but also have them
take the synaptive through those twice a
day and then the secret secret don't
tell anybody but it's in the book dial
MD for murder not in the book in the in
the CD dial MD for murder
he needs to have three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks now Becca you've seen me
eat breakfast so you know
that I eat eggs every morning soft
boiled soft poached soft sauce scramble
and butter no fried eggs and no
hard-boiled egg because they won't count
and that's going to help rebuild the
brain and all his nerves and all this
that and the other and so that's where I
would go with this guy
he's going to support his immune system
support his
um all his systems of his body
including his immune system also if he
does have these nasal sinus things it
wouldn't hurt for him to use our our
um colloidal silver he could put two
drivers pull that under his tongue 30
minutes for each meal and 30 minutes for
a bedtime and there's no alcohol and it
won't burn sting even if you have an
open wound but it will kill bugs been
used as an antibiotic for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years or were
you
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and my friend Angelica writes in the
chat she says I used to have migraines
seven years ago and she is migraine free
thank you Dr Wallach all right
excited I mean I hear people all the
time Dr Wallach
just reaching out through text message
through emails through phone calls
wanting to thank you because of what
they no longer have to deal with
okay
don't kill very good and of course
um again we have 21 best-selling books
we have four new ones coming out one of
which is yours the wallet Revolution
okay we're very very it's not that one's
not mine Dr Wallach I'm not going to
take credit for that one there's a
committee that for Better Health that
put that one together and they did a
fabulous job
I just have like the last little section
so yeah no that's that's a great book
I'm excited about that one as well yeah
it's coming out soon so I think the book
itself is done we're just working on you
know the cover and that kind of stuff
and so that should be done here pretty
quickly
yep that cover should be approved today
so and then off to the publisher and
printer it goes wow um yeah so I'm super
excited about that
now let's go to some more questions Dr
Wallach okay and again for everybody
that is here with us Dr Wallach he does
speak quite fast he wants to get as many
people in
um to the program
as possible because there's so many
people that are hurting so if you can
relate to any of the symptoms and
conditions that is that are mentioned
and want to hear the protocol again go
to ask doc
live.com and there you'll be able to
find all of the replays from all of our
programs since July of 2020. I think
there's one that's missing but for the
most part
um they're all there for you now Joseph
who's on with us he has a question he
wants to know can an individual have too
much protein
okay we can eat too much of anything
okay you have too much oxygen and so
okay and so to answer that question is
difficult can a person eat too much
protein
um it's how you cook the Protein it's
important
if you eat burnt
um Meats meat cook well done okay
um you're in trouble okay because
there's fat in meat and you're going to
I have a problem if you're getting your
protein from whole grains like we've
brought around oats you're doomed to die
early and be miserable before you die
okay and so
um yeah that's why we like the three
eggs twice a day I do eat lamb chops I
do eat cod fish I do eat salmon I do eat
chicken of the sea okay
and don't forget your steak doctor oh
yeah you have red meat oh yeah but
medium rare medium rare medium rare or
the the rare part is warm okay so you're
not eating frozen meat but it's it's
warm but it's not browned when you when
the when the entire piece of meat when
you cut through it is
cooked seriously and all browned and the
outside has you know so maybe even some
little burnt edges or something like
that don't eat it
and what you want to do is freeze it box
it up and give it as a present to your
doctor
well I still wouldn't give it to my
doctor I would send them a note with
information
on which page of your book to read about
eating burnt meat so that's what I would
do
and speaking of your books Dr Wallach so
Tammy has followed the instructions in
chapter 11 of rare Earth's forbidden
cures that's this big Dandy book
and she's had the hair analysis done
now she has some questions about it she
says she's off the chart on zirconium
and her husband is high in Arsenic and
aluminum
also selenium is high we've been taking
our selenium supplements do we back off
on the selenium
um and it also says
well Tammy will address the next part of
it but Dr Wallach what can they do
they're already taking the youngevity
products and I know that they're on the
healthy body pack possibly since they're
taking the selenium the brain and heart
pack for each of them what can they do
to help bring down the zirconium the
Arsenic and the aluminum
okay well here's where our herbal
rainforest comes in it has 13 cleansing
herbs and 75 minerals in it and uh you
know it goes by weight I'm going to take
a one ounce per 100 pounds of body
weight per day and it's designed to
naturally lower and remove toxic metals
and to help stabilize your nutritional
minerals okay and if all of your
minerals are below the bottom line uh
that means that you're eating gluten and
buckwheat your intestines are dead and
you can't absorb nutrition so that's
that's useful information okay you got
to get rid of the bad stuff so you can
absorb nutrition but your first picture
when you first look at your first hair
analysis no matter if you're
supplementing or not your your minerals
your nutritional minerals should be kind
of all over the place okay
um and so what you're looking for is to
stabilize all that you stabilize all
that by getting rid of the bad stuff so
that you're going to absorb all the
nutrition because each mineral has a
different efficiency of absorption
because of a size and shape and
chemistry and so forth and so that's all
part of it but also when you take the
herbal rainforest it was designed to
naturally get rid of the toxic metals
like lead and mercury and Arsenic and
although a small amount of arsenic is
essential uh
one of those things where even oxygen
too much oxygen is fatal okay you want
the ideal optimal amount of oxygen you
don't want it too low you don't want too
high you want it right where it's
supposed to be same way with arsenic you
don't want to totally gone but you do
want it you know in the what you see in
the normal uh supportive range and of
course that's all on the paper you get
back on the hair analysis
um you get the book rarest from
Interiors go to chapters 10 11 start at
page 272 and it'll tell you how to
collect the hair how to package it or to
ship it don't forget to put the check or
money order in there because the labs
won't run the test without they've been
messing around with so many times they
they don't run the test without the
check or money order being put in there
in the package
and in a couple of weeks you get these
two charts back I mean this is something
we all should be doing once a year uh
especially if you travel
and when you travel of course you're
going places or eating places you don't
know who they are what they are what
they do and so on you don't know what
factories are on there uh where the
crops are growing and so on and so it's
one of those things where and I get
people all the time Becca who say oh
yeah I was in the military for 10 12 15
20 years and I know I've got all these
toxic things in me okay well let's do a
hair analysis
and it comes back and they don't have
any toxic metals like lead and Mercury
they're all shocked well I thought sure
I was going to have high levels of those
things but you know it just depends on
how careful you were in the environment
uh were you handling all those things or
were they in the building next door kind
of thing and so you know it's worth
having that test done once a year and
it's a tax deduction along with your
health uh care costs tax deduction if
you're running the youngevity business
as a business and just like you get the
deduct a portion of your mortgage your
rent you get to deduct uh the same
percentage of your
utilities you get thousands of dollars
back at the end of the year tax
deductions if you run your youngevity
business out of your home don't go buy
or rent a place in the mall don't do
that you're already renting your space
at home you take advantage of that
okay
yes absolutely and you had mentioned
about two weeks well Dr Wallach we've
had such an influx of people wanting to
do the hair analysis it is taking up to
four weeks so folks be patient as we get
everybody's hair analysis done Dr
Wallach does look through them before
they're getting them send out now
um so that if something it really
catches his eye and it's like okay let's
call this person or email this person or
include a note
we're actually getting that added with
the hair analysis whenever before they
go out now so it does take us a little
bit more time to do that but it's all
about quality and providing each and
every one of you a quality experience
because
rushing rushing through is what got us
to where we're at today folks when it
comes to poor health think about it
processed foods everything fast and
simple drive-throughs fast food all of
those things if you look at charts you
can see an incline in poor health
conditions
well we want to make sure that we give
you quality time and that's part of why
we provide this program to you to make
sure that you're getting quality
information that's actually going to
benefit you
today tomorrow
and in years to come
so
thank you so much for that question yeah
you're welcome so yes Tammy herbal
rainforest is a great one to add to your
protocol and the thing about herbal
rainforest my experience I take it at
night
and if you've got sensitive bowels you
might want to take half a teaspoon at
night or a half sorry
half an ounce at night before bed and
work up to a full ounce
because as it is working at the cellular
level it's also helping to clean out the
bowels so you don't want to have too
much
um and then create a
an issue the next day if you have to go
to work or be away from an area where a
bathroom is convenient because that's
part of the detox folks that's just
that's nature
when the body is trying to get rid of
something how is it going to get rid of
it
well most of the time it goes to the
digestive system it pushes it into the
digestive system and it has to evacuate
somehow so without being too graphic
it's a good thing to be able to get rid
of things that are in the body because
that's just one sign that the body's not
happy
whenever you've got conditions that
create irritable bowels
digestive issues I mean these are all
red warning lights right Dr Wallach
that's correct
that's correct you want to pay attention
to the red warning lights that's for
sure
yeah absolutely now
um just a reminder if you are here with
us and would like to ask Dr Wallach a
question you are more than welcome to
raise your hand we do have lots of
people putting in questions in the chat
and then I have emails that I'll get to
as well
that come into us here at askdoc live
and critical Health news and if you
personally have a question or would like
to set up a time to speak with one of
our certified holistic health coaches go
to
askdoclive.com this is especially for
those who have never spoken to anybody
about any youngevity products before if
you were referred to this program or
you've spoken with somebody about
youngevity or the products get back with
them chances are they have gone through
our health coach certification course
also which is available to you just get
with them they'll be able to help you
with the information needed to enroll in
that course you do not have to use it
for business you can use it for your own
personal knowledge to help yourself and
your family and that program is provided
by a Institute of holistic health
and you can find information at
Institute of holistichealth.com now
holistic is spelled with a wh not just
an H because we look at the whole body
and in our course we actually teach and
go deeper into Dr wallach's research and
what he has found to be the four areas
of Health how they're affected by
nutritional deficiencies
and our solution in order to
what's the right word that I can use not
being a healthcare professional
um help to relieve those deficiencies
for for you and those that you love so
and then if you want to make it a
business we teach you how to make it
into a business as well
now Jacqueline thank you so much for
raising your hand because I wasn't quite
um understanding your question so go
ahead and unmute yourself
okay can you hear me I can welcome to
ass doc live my dear well thank you
thank you for asking that question I
just have a quick question for Doc if
someone has taken ingresia because they
have no control of their tongue is that
a lifetime a prescription they're going
to have to take
okay I missed the first part of that I
didn't understand the word you said
okay I'm sorry hello
all right it's a prescription called
ingresia Dr Wallach
right okay I don't know what andresia is
well it causes something when somebody
but this person has no control of their
tongue oh and that's easy that's easy
yeah because of some other medication
that caused the problem and now that
you're under this
whenever they you know if they don't
take it then they can't they have no
control of their tongue and I'm just
wondering is that going to be a lifetime
prescription
okay no because I'm assuming this person
is an adult is that correct yes yes 50
year old that's my daughter yeah okay
well the odds are they have osteoporosis
of skull squeezing the ninth uh cranial
nerve okay uh the tongue the The Voice
the swallow uh reflex all that kind of
stuff gag reflex
um is all impacted uh by the the ninth
Trail nerve being squeezed by
osteoporosis of the skull
okay and so
um this person needs to get rid of all
the bad foods and per 100 pounds of body
weight they need one healthy brain and
heart pack per month they need the MSM
um per 100 pounds of body weight they
need one bottle a month the MSM saying
take three twice a day support
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
Ray bone makes your bone itself
including the skull okay
okay then they need the
um
um Beyond Osteo effects uh scuba that
with the moring drinks without the
evening drink the collagen peptides a
scuba that in the morning with their
drink and screw with that it was their
drink in the evening and then vitamin D
three three of those twice a day all
important and
um it usually takes anywhere from 10 to
14 days to begin to see something happen
I always say give me 90 days but usually
within two weeks
um you're seeing a great Improvement and
you usually within four to six weeks
that problem's gone even if they've had
it for years okay and again it's one of
the 37 different diseases you get from
osteoporosis of the skull everybody
doesn't get all 37 diseases they usually
they'll get three or four or five or six
of them they're obvious clinically and
they complain about and if somebody
really closely examines them they may
see two or three others but very few get
all 37 at the same time so one of the
questions you want to ask this person
how many times do they get up at night
to urinate uh none once three times five
times ten times because when the skull
the squeezing the cranial nerves it's
also screening squeezing the spinal cord
and when the spinal cord gets squeezed
it will tell the urinary bladder to
urinate okay and so that's a good clue
okay okay thank you so much I appreciate
that bye-bye
all right thank you Jacqueline thank you
now Dr Wallach I have many many
questions that come into us and Mark is
asking the question
where did it go sorry folks
so he has tinnitus balance problems he
doesn't pee as much as he used to he has
dry eyes
trouble swallowing
and sometimes
um he chokes on big pills
okay what how old is this guy
he doesn't have an H
um but if it's the person that I'm
thinking of he's he's in his 60s okay
well
what does this give you this gives you a
clue what his problem is
he's got classic Aussie approaches to
the skull classic obviously approaches
to the skull okay and so he needs to get
this book in the CD and then of course
he needs to get rid of all the bad foods
he needs to
um per 100 pounds of body weight he's
taking a healthy brand heart back he
needs the MSM he needs the collagen
peptides he needs to be on Osteo FX he
needs vitamin D3 He needs also the um
synaptive I'd have him take that three
eggs twice a day of soft yolks and so
this is a classic example of
osteoporosis of the skull
that's what I was thinking as I was
reading through his email I'm like
osteoporosis of the skull osteoporosis
of the skull osteoporosis of the skull
now he mentioned dry eyes is that also
linked to osteoporosis of the skull oh
absolutely okay because
um the nerves that produce the tears
are getting squeezed
by the skull just like the optic nerve
is being squeezed uh you say slowly lose
their Vision optic nerve optic artery
optic vein will get squeezed and um then
the people of the eye gets funny they
lose their Vision
tearing and but it's all due to the
skull squeezing the optic nerves and all
the ancillary branches of those nerves
including to the tiered tear glands
okay so the squeezing of those nerves
and you're feeling pain or discomfort or
some type of symptom elsewhere
that would be a referred symptom right
maybe you could also have obstacrosis
everywhere in the body
okay now if you're talking about the
skull
um again the fifth cranial nerve being
squeezed you get trigeminal neuralgia I
mean we're talking about pitching the
face with a hammer type pain right yeah
lots of pain what's in the face and it
could be
I I know people that have had pain in
their cheeks like in their job their jaw
bones yeah below their eyes that's the
fifth cranial nerve being squeeze yeah
and it's not always in one place that's
correct
on one side and not the other it doesn't
hit me on both sides
yeah
and then he had also mentioned
um
as off en
so could that be
yes also yeah again uh it has to do with
the the signals that the spinal cord is
giving the urinary bladder
and if the signals are drying up then of
course they won't urinate as often
all right well and folks your nation is
a good thing
our good thing
but like with bowel movements with each
time that you eat you should have a
bowel movement the more you eat the more
bowel movement you have as far as
drinking you should be drinking plenty
of fluids do not stop drinking because
you think you pee too much
that's where dehydration comes in you
need to keep your body hydrated you need
to hydrate with minerals mineral Rich
drinks like the rebound like the Beyond
tingy Tangerine us with Osteo FX in
there I shake it every time before I
take a drink and I have my straw here so
that I can drink and suck up everything
that starts to settle I get that up
first so there's nothing left at the
bottom when I'm done drinking my liquids
and then I love Dr Wallach our mineral
sticks
and so I was a little hesitant I'm going
to be honest with you folks the mineral
sticks
they tasted really good when I had
powder all over my hand and I licked it
off just like a kid with those pixie
stick things
but when I put it in water it had a
little bit of a tartness
but I found the other day when I mixed
it with plain Greek full fat yogurt it
is amazing
so not only am I getting a full dose of
minerals the Dr Wallach found to be
needed per 100 pounds to thrive but I'm
also getting a full dose of collagen
peptides
so Dr Wallach collagen peptides
tell us what that's good for okay well
are you good for bones and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue including the skin the walls the
intestine the trachea you know in your
lungs uh you're looking at the cartilage
in your hips and your knees your bones
the minerals are sitting in collagen and
of course we first did that you know for
um our great basketball stars of
the our first one is glucogel is
collagen from beef and then of course we
have the collagen uh let's see here we
have the collagen
um uh
see so we have a couple different
collagens we have the gluco gel
yeah the glucajel is our first one
that's just beef but then the collagen
peptides are fish poultry sheep and beef
all at the same time
five different types of collagen now the
reason why we did that you have to
appreciate in the old days people used
to make what was called bone broth
I don't know if you're old enough to
remember bone broth grandma would take
the chicken bones the turkey bones the
beef bones the rib bones uh you know the
vertebrae any any bones you could get
and throw them in some vinegar water and
put them on the stove at night we'd all
go to bed in the morning the heat would
be pulling all the minerals out of the
bones in that in that vinegar water and
we'd fight over that because we knew
that would help relieve pain and
inflammation in your joints and this and
the other but it's it's kind of a messy
thing and so people don't do that
anymore and so what we did we learned
that
um we can actually dry those
um collagen peptides
okay and then put them in
um you know the products like collagen
peptides and and so forth and so
um that's why we have those so that we
can get the
um cartilage taken care of and the
connective tissue tendons ligament skin
skin is two-thirds of the thickness of
the skin is the same connective tissue
it makes up tendons
uh when you look at the weight of your
dried lungs and your trachea and bronch
and everything most of it is cartilage
and connective tissue
because your trachea and Bronco are you
know very very thick with uh cartilage
okay and so uh we came up with a form of
what we said okay we have to come up
with kind of a bone broth thing and
that's why we came up with a collagen
peptides and the glucogel
well I started with the glucogel Dr
Wallach and I was doing the five three
times a day and I have people that are
like that's a lot well
my health was important to me I was sick
and tired of being sick and tired so
taking five three times a day
was so worth it and now that we have the
collagen peptides one thing that I love
about our collagen peptides because I've
tried others is it does not have a foul
smell and it does not have a foul taste
I can add it to my teas I can add it to
my Tangy Tangerine I can add it to my
yogurt and it doesn't change the flavor
yeah you can put an applesauce for
little kids
and you can yeah you can put it in
applesauce absolutely
well on that I know Dr Wallach he is top
of the hour let's go ahead everybody get
up and stretch oh and one more thing
before I forget so I'm gonna contribute
taking the five three times a day of the
glucogel and adding the collagen
peptides to
the reason why after losing a hundred
pounds I don't have a lot of extra skin
not on my neck I mean yeah anybody can
have some extra skin but it's it's not
sagging I don't have it on my arms
sagging
um and I just love the fact that I've
been able to support my body as a whole
in this whole Health journey of
relieving the inflammation relieving the
pain the discomfort the disease
and the extra weight so if anybody is
interested in
this weight aspect of Health
and in finding Health losing the extra
weight make sure you go to
askdoclive.com click on contact us and
reach out to me I am going to be
starting a Kickstart for our keto
program
that we're officially going to be
starting
it's either the 8th or the 15th of
January okay
and
that gives you time to get the
information that you need the products
that you need so that you can jump in
and join us in this journey of
2020 23 and making sure that you reach
Optimal Health and weight at the same
time so we will be right back after this
short break again get up and stretch
and get something to drink make sure you
stay hydrated we'll be right back
all right thank you everybody for
staying here with us on ass doc live
again if you were invited to watch this
program by somebody specific make sure
that you get back with that person they
took the time because they cared enough
to share this information with you so
that you can take control of your own
health and it doesn't matter if you are
super sick but have a will to live or if
you're super healthy and want to stay
healthy
supplementation through what Dr Wallach
has found through his many many many
years I mean decades folks of research
is what we are offering to you today not
just to survive but actually Thrive and
make a difference in your life and the
life of others now I know Dr Wallach was
here for just a moment and then left
again so as soon as he gets back we will
pick up with some more questions but I
want to make sure that if you are on
live with us and you have a question for
Dr Wallach raise your virtual hand make
sure we want to make sure that your
questions your concerns are being heard
because other people probably have the
same questions and the same concerns
also about their health
that's one thing that
I have found to be true like here in the
United States
we are a Melting Pot of so many
different cultures from around the world
and as our
food changes start adapting to what
I consider the sad diet and it's
actually very well known as the sad diet
it's a standard American diet folks
fast food processed whatever we can get
from the center of the store that's in a
box you add water you throw in the
microwave
folks those things do not have the
nutrition that we need and even if we're
sticking to the outside
area of the store where the fruits and
vegetables are the meats the dairy we
want to be very picky because we are
worth it we don't want to go for the
cheapest stuff I used to go for the
cheapest stuff I had a family of five
children
with one income
and we wanted to you know make ends meet
well that trying to make ends meet and
skimping on our own health so that we
could do other things that were not as
important
really contributed to decline of Health
for myself my children
and
now I'm just thankful that I have woken
up how that I've received information
that is now
beneficial in my health each and every
day and I am here and able to share it
with you
so look for those things that say
hormone free
grass fed
organic
and I do want you to realize organic
does not necessarily mean more nutrition
but it does have
some clout with me when it comes to less
pesticides
less hormones
non-GMO less antibiotics used within the
animals
you know all of these things that we
don't want in our bodies because we're
giving our bodies what it needs to have
a healthy immune system where we can
guard ourselves protect ourselves
and if we do get sick we bounce back
quicker
so there's a lot of things that we can
do to help ourselves
okay
so if you have a question please don't
hesitate to raise your hand
um if we don't have questions and people
are just listening in that's fabulous
too because I have so many emails that
come in with questions now if you are
part of the critical Health news or the
askdoc live
subscriber base for the newsletter make
sure that you check your email we have
had some
technology
I don't want to say difficulties but
with technology it is absolutely
fabulous when it works the way it was
designed to and then whenever a company
that you trust does a little upgrade and
it changes everything
then we have to do special things like
send out an email saying hey if you want
to continue to be a subscriber of our
newsletter please reply to this
newsletter and let us know so please
please please if you are one of our
subscribers and there's almost 70 000 of
you out there right now
please go to your emails and just do a
simple reply and say hi that's all we
need to know that you want to continue
to receive our newsletter so
I know that there's some questions
coming up in the chat and as soon as Dr
Wallach gets back with us here
um we will be going in through those
questions
so Dr Wallach if you can hear the sound
of my voice come back we miss you
foreign
I like having this camera on because
then I can see that he's there
but anyways
um I want to take this time to to thank
all of you for being on with us
we have almost 60 people on with us
right now which I think is absolutely
fabulous I love the fact that many of
you have your cameras on and you're able
to show your smiling faces or you have
profile pictures up where I can see your
smiling faces and more people are
popping on with their cameras thank you
so much that just really
um
brightens my heart because
knowing that there are more people that
are like-minded
and seeking options
is just encouraging
so so encouraging for those of us who
have options that have been proven to be
beneficial and I love seeing lots of our
coach graduates from the certified
holistic health coach course
we just want to thank you
for for joining us and and inviting
somebody
folks this program is being brought to
you as a resource a resource that you
can share with your family with your
friends with your clients whether you're
in this as a business and as a health
coach helping others or not this
information can change lives
and we want to make sure that we are
providing impactful information that
changes lives in a good way
all right
we need
90 essential nutrients each and every
day
each and every day it's like putting gas
in the car
you stop putting gas in your car it's
going to eventually quit
do you stop changing the oil
and you're going to have a lot of
symptoms before it quits
so we are putting gas in our bodies as a
vehicle as a temple we are putting the
oil in our bodies to help
ward off a lot of those things that are
affecting so many people
in this world
so there he is
welcome back Dr Welling thank you thank
you we missed you well yeah there's
alarms going off so I had to go check
all the doors and everything
yeah all right well I'm
I I'm sure you found that everything was
okay right we're back yes we're back
all right well let me go with Ryan's
question from the chat and then we have
some hands up
so Ryan is
and I don't know if this is Ryan or in
regards to somebody that he's working
with
um 25 year old male
five foot six
130 pounds
um mild health problems his teeth are
moving and his gums are receding
uh he also has noisy joints vertigo
hearing loss tinnitus varicose veins
spider veins pain in feet when sitting
too long
uh sometimes see new veins uh Spider or
indented
hypoglycemia which is improving and his
question is what youngevity products
should I take
what should I eat
and not for my osteoporosis is what he's
guessing and I'm you're a pretty good
guesser there Ryan
um
okay and then he had some questions
about some different
uh minerals and wanting to know how they
would compete with other minerals so he
has taken chromium
um with the sweeties with each meal to
help with the hypoglycemia so that's a
great place to start and folks 25 years
old having all of these health
conditions
that's where I was
so Ryan don't lose hope
because
your body
has a hundred years to go my friend been
feeling great so Dr Wallach what would
you recommend for Ryan who has
osteoporosis of the skull
will you get an A-Plus exactly right he
has honesty approaches Cisco and
um uh it's one of those things where the
teeth floating around receding gums
because your jaw is part of the skull so
as a jaw squeezes the gums are too much
for the shrunken Jaws so it kind of
recede and loose teeth okay because the
jaw is shrinking
um and he's got tinnitus ringing in the
ears okay that has to do with the eighth
the vascular branch of the atrial nerve
being squeezed or assuming the auditory
branches are being squeezed
um
and then let's see here balance and all
that kind of stuff in the joints all
over the body we have obviously
approached to the skull it's guaranteed
you already have osteoporosis everywhere
else in the body you don't just have it
in one bone okay and so and it has an
osteoporosis is not an age thing babies
are born with osteoporosis of the skull
babies are born with osteoporosis so
their leg bones and stuff like that and
so it has nothing to do with age and
it's a good thing that he's doing the
sweeties of course for his hypoglycemia
which is a different issue but it's one
of those things where this is why people
say well which mineral is it which
mineral is it and it's a little more
complicated than that so in
130 pounds I think yeah 130 pounds we
want him to get rid of all the bad foods
and maximize absorption relieve
inflammation no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no cooking oils no salad
dressings uh no gluten no wheat nobody
Ryan oats no buckwheat absolutely no
sugar no carbonator drinks and because
carbonation
neutralizes stomach acid and also
um
or reduces the efficiency of absorption
and also
the
digestion of food okay because it
neutralizes the stomach acid then we
need to make sure that this guy is
getting at 130 pounds with all this
going on at his age I was still giving
two healthy brain and heart pressure
he's right on that cusp of his body
weight so I'd give him two healthy brain
and heart pasture month of everything
twice a day and um then he needs at
least one bottle better he had two
bottles of the MSM so we take three with
breakfast we use laundry dinner time
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between a vertebrae bone makes bone
himself
and then he also needs to take the
collagen peptides to scuba that with
breakfast or scuba that with dinner okay
and his drink he needs to be on Osteo
effects of scuba that was his breakfast
drink and evening drink vitamin D3 of
those twice a day
and
um let's see here I do want him to use
our rebound or a sports drink I'd um if
he's he can use the sticks he could use
the canister if he wants to use the cans
he's got to pop the cans at night uh put
them in the refrigerator and only drink
them in the morning after all the bubbly
is gone because he doesn't want that
carbonation and these issues will all go
away very quickly usually in two to six
weeks he's going to see major
Improvement but I always say give us 90
days because if he's been eating gluten
all his life uh wheat butter on oats
um you know the Breakfast of Champions
and oatmeal and you know he he like
Bruce Lee and that kind of stuff it's
one of those things where he's got to
heal
uh everything not just not just his
skull but he's got to heal his entire
body including his intestines and so
forth but this is all fixable same way
with the veins you know when you get a
breakdown of collagen just remember the
walls of your veins and arteries are
also made out of collagen okay so that's
why he's got varicose veins and that
kind of stuff in him at his young age
okay but that all that's all healable
stuff
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
so Ryan lots of information there make
sure that if you didn't catch it all go
ahead and go to our website
askdoclive.com and you want to look at
oh probably about
an hour 20 minutes into it so that you
can get your information repeated to you
Dr Wallach let's go to the first Chan
that is up into the line today
and
we go to David David go ahead and unmute
yourself
hi Dr Wallach hello David
how old are you how much you weigh
I weigh 182 pounds okay
um I haven't osteoporosis of the skull
and last week I was on and you
recommended some products
um additional products to what I was
already taking that I received today
my question is as these products have
their effects does the skull go back to
its original size to relieve the
pressure eventually yes the skull will
go back to its normal architecture and
size uh all tissues in the body want to
be normal okay and if you give it the
raw materials and stay away from the bad
stuff which causes inflammation changes
in shape it all goes back to normal
when you give it all the good stuff and
take away the bad stuff I don't care if
you're 100 years old it'll still go back
to normal okay
okay great thank you you bet
okay Rebecca all right thank you David
so let me put my Spotlight up here
because we have a question
um with youngevity we have some amazing
collagen products several different
products that
are are recommended for different site
because skin conditions so we have a
collagen peptides for
Hair Skin and Nail Formula we have one
that's a joint formula we have a
collagen gummy which is awesome and then
earlier I mentioned our mineral sticks
which have collagen in them but the one
that Dr Wallach is referring to when
he's giving these protocols is in the
blue and white canister and it is just
the five types of collagen peptides so
that is a great question coach rod
it's the plain collagen peptide so this
is going to give you the most collagen
per dose where the others have amazing
cofactors or special ingredients that
help with the specific
condition that is on the container this
is collagen
in its best form
I I don't want to say it's the best form
Dr Wally because the other ones are
great too I mean I love our joint health
with hot water and drink it at night
with a calming tea
it's absolutely wonderful
yeah well you have to remember that in
the beginning we only had the glucogel
and we put that in with our healthy
shark pack for Theo Ratliff we call it
the healthy Bone and Joint pack and of
course he was 24 years old had bone bone
arthritis in both his knees he had uh
the cartilage slip off his right hip he
had a fracture of his shooting arm wrist
his right arm he lost his 35 million
dollar contract to the Atlanta Hawks and
he's only 24 years old and we came up
with a healthy Bone and Joint pack for
him and that's where we came up with a
glucogel we didn't at that time we
didn't have a collagen product but we
came up with a gluco gel to produce
acknowledging and
um we rebuilt him in about six months he
came back got his contract back with the
Atlanta Hawks he played for 11 years
made a hundred million dollars using our
product to maintain his joints now do
you think he likes our collagen peptides
do you think he likes our Luca gel of
course
that's you know that for such a small
change
in your diet to have such a monetary
impact
yes
that's incredible
absolutely incredible and we're not even
made the body's been made to do
remarkable incredible things
yes it is and when you give the body the
raw ingredients that it
Thrive it just starves for
because that's you know those are the
raw ingredients that
were made from
so we need to continually give those
minerals yeah that's one of those things
where the medical treatment for that
would be just say Cortisone and aspirin
and stuff like that to treat the
symptoms and that's why we came up with
the CD called dial MD for murder okay or
just like the movie dial in for murder
because
the doctors even yet today
their first move is to relieve pain So
the patient's happy okay pain gone and
you know come back in in a month we'll
see how you're doing well you know
without if all you're giving is a pain
reliever you're not going to rebuild all
the joints and bones in the body with a
pain reliever okay and so he said yeah
it's starting to come back a little bit
but that whatever you gave me the first
time was good so you give them a shot
and then give him a stronger pain
reliever oh man
now come back in a month oh this is good
this is good and they're happy but in
two years time then they have to have a
double knee replacement double hip
replacement or maybe they'll amputate
the leg and put in an artificial leg and
so forth and so it's one of those things
where
um
you have to take it all and give
everything the tissue needs whether it's
the liver the heart the eye the brain uh
the kidneys the muscles the intestines
the stomach the lungs they all need
stuff and so this is why we have the
various programs we have to provide all
the stuff okay
well our body has two filtering systems
Dr Wallach the kidneys and the liver
no yeah liver
so as we're taking all those chemicals
those those two organs
are filtering out those chemicals
because they're trying to protect our
bodies
and then when those organs become full
of the chemicals especially the liver
what happens whenever you put chemicals
on anything folks
it starts to disintegrate it starts to
quit working
so having all those Pharmaceuticals and
things that are just masking symptoms
it's taxing on other parts of your body
so I really encourage you to
look at the core Foundation the
underlying cause as to why the things
are starting to go wrong in the body and
that's nutritional deficiencies
so Dr Wallach let's go to the next hand
that is up and Gary go ahead and unmute
yourself
okay doc I saw I was uh with you on
Tuesday on the radio show okay
um I have a testimonial I gave you a
testimonial on Tuesday about my hair you
said I look like Santa Claus last year I
still look like Santa Claus a little bit
but I'm beginning beginning to get black
hair on top here
right here now look at this picture this
picture is of me
two years ago
that's pretty white on top there Gary
it's pretty white on top
there's me I don't know can you see any
black Sean yes we got some dark hair
coming in and I see it in your mustache
as well yeah okay now I have a I have a
surgeon I have a doctor that wants to
operate on me now listen to what
happened quickly and then I can get off
I don't want to stay on too long I'm
taking all your supplements I'm taking
the collagen peptides this is for a
whole year now I'm on the um the uh
selenium the the niacin I had a blood
clot in my leg you told me I was low in
omega-3 fatty acids I'm on them I'm on
the on on the um
Heidi brain and health pack I'm on the
MSM or no Ms yeah MSM right MSM and um
I put I strained myself uh a couple
weeks ago and I developed a hernia
he wants to operate on me on January
26th I'm wearing a belt right now you
told me to go get a belt I had a belt
before you even told me to go get it
what should I do tell me
okay well I would as an inguinal hernia
yes you're growing okay yeah I'll use
that belt and it has the pad okay okay
and you want to put a
um four by four under the feet of your
bed and showing your sleep you're
elevated your legs are elevated so all
your intestines are going to move away
from that hernia and it might take a
couple of months but it will heal
okay that's what my question was about a
couple months you think right because he
wants to operate on I'm going to prolong
the operate I don't think I want to get
operated on
well personally I wouldn't that's your
decision but I would not get the surgery
when I can do it myself I don't feel
anything with the belt I'm I'm perfectly
comfortable right now well there you go
so you so so in from from your
profession and in inguinal hernia with
the proper nutrition could heal itself
with the proper nutrition and the proper
mechanics so you're taking the pressure
off of that wound okay so so it's not
it's not an untruth that it will not
heal because all the surges the doctors
say oh no no no you need an operation
okay well what you need to ask the
doctor is how many kids he has in
college and his tuition do
I I got it
thank you
you're welcome keep us informed all
right when you're healed when the
England when the inguinal hernia is
healed is actually you know mended okay
you want to keep wearing that belt for
another year okay keep the pressure off
of it so it doesn't split open again
okay oh I I should keep it on for about
a holy okay a whole year okay yes gotcha
all right okay because people people I
get so many calls on hernias belly
button hernias any little hernias uh but
they're easily healed but you have to do
all the mechanical stuff with the belts
okay in the pads uh put the four by
fours under the uh feet of the bed and
uh you know do do all that stuff take
your enzymes don't forget no your
supplements you want to take your
ultimate enzymes so that you don't have
a big bowel movement sitting there for
two days putting pressure on it right
right I have no problem with that I have
I have Becca I have to ask tell you one
thing you said that you don't use any
lotion anymore because you're taking
omega-3 fatty acids and all the
nutrients guess what for a whole year
this is the first time that I do not put
any lotion on my hands or on my lips
that's fantastic yeah
awesome Gary
okay that's it I don't want to keep you
anymore thank you you're really welcome
so oh I'm sorry Gary you didn't want to
talk anymore so I muted you
all right so one thing that I wanted to
kind of expound on that Dr Wallach with
Gary and the reason why you mentioned to
keep the belt keep using the belt and
use those pads is you're pushing that
hernia into place where it's supposed to
be and whenever the body's not trying to
work against it then that connective
tissue can come back into the place
where it's supposed to be because it's
like a tear in the connective tissue
that is create allowing the Bulge of the
things on the other side to come out so
we want to make sure that that gets
pushed in and held in place while the
body does what it needs to do to
strengthen
am I right Dr Wallace yes it's the
equivalent of putting a cast on a broken
leg I put the cast in the broken leg to
help keep things in place the cast
doesn't help the the wound heal but it
allows it to heal by keeping it from
falling apart and the same thing is true
with that um belt in the pad it holds
everything in the proper place so it can
heal properly
yes
all right thank you so much
um so doctor well like I want to go back
to this picture oops this picture
okay because I have a lot of people that
write in in say osteoporosis of the
skull the skull looks thicker well isn't
thicker better
and when we when we look at this let's
also look at the amount of room that's
inside here where the brain is housed
so if that skull you see this black area
here
if you if that space is no longer
existent then it's squeezing the brain
too isn't it that is correct the
squeezing the brain which affects the
circulation of the brain of um you know
the cerebral spinal fluid as well as
blood and so on and so it's squeezing
the brain is that's why we have memory
effects and we have synaptive all these
kind of things to help the brain you
need to be eating your your three eggs
twice a day for for the cholesterol
which rebuild the white matter of the
brain okay and so it's one of those
things where
um these are all simple slash complex
things
okay they're simple because the
knowledge makes the repair simple but
you're dealing with a an organ that has
blood supply lymph Supply nerve Supply
it has bone it has nerve cells it's got
your blood vessels all the stuff going
on in there the cerebral spinal fluid
and so you have to give everything that
it needs plus support it so it's not
under pressure so its energies are not
dealing with dealing with the outside
world as opposed to just doing the
normal physiology
right and and it's not that the bone
thicker is better
no is that bone itself is not getting
thicker it's being filled in with
connective tissue that's correct it's me
it's kind of like skin tissues it's
these dermises so tendons uh that's
actually tendon material okay it's not
bone
and so
um the medical system really has no
understanding of osteoporosis of the
skull uh because you can ask your doctor
is it possible to have osteoporosis
called don't just laugh at you there's
never been a report of osteoporosis
called just usually the vertebrae and
the you know the long bones in your legs
and arms and stuff like that but no no
there's never been any reports of
osteoporosis skull well I'm a
pathologist I used to see it all the
time and so it's one of those things
where okay it's time to write something
on it okay and that's where we came up
with the book
um in the CD to get that information out
there so at least
and of course it's there's a steady flow
of these books and CDs out the door
every day okay it's one of our most
commonly purchased books and CDs right
now because it's kind of a New Concept
and people are getting that to their
families it's a holiday they want to
give it to them as gifts because
Grandma's got osteoposis of skill and
they're not a doctor but they can see
the symptoms that are listed in the book
They're saying okay well Grandma's got
five of those 37 symptoms so she's got
osteoporosis of this goal and so that's
why these books and CDs are going out
the door so rapidly because it's very
common and doctors do not want you to
know that osteoposis of the skull is a
reversible and repairable
a dilemma so that because if you can
repair
how she posted a skull what does that
mean oh that means you can repair
osteoporosis your leg bones your arm
bones your pelvis your knees your hips
your neck your vertebrae and you won't
need surgery you won't need double knee
replacement you won't need double hip
replacement
and that's where the orthopedic search
get their income from from doing those
procedures and so when people all start
doing all the right things the
oh she say they call you know something
not using the n-word not using the need
word okay the call for double knee
replacement by the doctor and you're in
such pain you say well whatever needs to
be done just let's do it okay no
um we can we can rebuild
your knees we can rebuild your hips we
can build your pillows you can build
your rebuild your skull uh these have
circulation uh all your cells are still
alive and it's a good thing
yes it is and it just made sense to me
Dr Wallach because I was told that I had
osteoporosis
and
many different things
and whenever I heard your message about
osteoporosis of the skull and how
everything is happening
up high
and affecting everything Downstream yes
you got it
it's like it made it so simple to
understand so we fixed what's going on
up high
everything Downstream you know things
flow Downstream
go damn bad so let's just uh let the
good stuff flow Dr Wallach
so I have um Angelica has a question
here she says
um
can you please talk briefly about
thyroid issues she has a client that's
gaining weight has gallstones
um the doctor wants to operate to flush
the gallstone out
and yeah I
wouldn't get an operation for gallstones
uh do we have any idea how much this
lady weighs yeah it's actually uh
okay so it looks like she has two
different ones no I don't have any
weight so let's just go buy a hundred
pounds okay per 100 pounds yeah she's
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat no bar Ryan oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonated drinks
and then per 100 pounds of body weight I
want to have one healthy pain and heart
pack per month
if she weighs 150 pounds it'll be two
tell the brand of heart packs per month
then I wanted to get at least one bottle
of MSM so you can take three twice a day
if she weighs 150 pounds it'll be two
bottles around them so you take three
three times a day and they'll rebuild
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between a vertebrae bone
makes bone itself including the skull
and everything Downstream including the
vertebrae and and
the collarbone and the arm bones and
shoulder joints and elbow joints and
fingers and trigger finger and of hammer
toes and hips and knees and all that
kind of stuff will all heal okay needs
the collagen peptides and scuba that
with the morning drinks do whatever the
evening drink the Beyond Osteo FX is too
with them in the morning drink and the
evening drink vitamin D three three of
those signs today and then
um if there's anything else going on
um obviously approaches to the skull
um wouldn't hurt to throw in the
synaptive for brain health don't forget
the three
eggs with soft yolks at breakfast and
dinner time and
um let's see here I think we're covering
all the
oh the thyroid okay let's go with the
thyroid
um the thyroid we have oceans gold she
could take three of those twice a day
that's two valves a month
um and also a few quite Z but the
capsules are if she prefers liquid which
I know you use is a z radical and it's
made from seaweed and algae and and that
sort of stuff eight or nine different
ones and getting all those minerals that
the thyroid loves and that's why sea
salt used to be and what was the first
supplement ever sold on Earth okay and
sea salt of course has all these sea
minerals in it as well as the minerals
in the salt and from the algae and and
the seaweed and Plankton and that kind
of stuff and the thyroid is very healthy
that was the first scientific paper I
wrote was a low thyroid and those sheep
that died uh 500 died in one night when
the temperature dropped and they've been
getting high nitrates from the
surrounding Farms and um it was a
Christmas
1963 all the professors are off and I'm
the students you know
um in learning in the Pathology
Department and the farmer brings me 50
dead sheep did all the work found out
that they all died of hypothyroidism
because of the temperature dropping and
they've been getting nitrates in their
drinking water for six months and so
they had goiter and when the temperature
dropped they could not sustain their
body temperature and they all died a
hypothermia so I wrote that up got it
published in two journals and using that
Marlin Perkins the old Mutual Omaha
Kingdom show used my paper to get a 25
million dollars per Grant actually it
was originally I think it was 7 million
but it it was over 10 years they had to
renew it all the time so it was
eventually over 20 million dollar Grant
did 20 000
um autopsies and
um published and my my thesis sold for
twenty five thousand dollars each was
five thousand pages so we made a summary
of it called epigenetics which created a
whole new science this is replacing
genetics epigenetics the death of Jake 3
disease transmission these sell for 25
bucks and so these fly out the door
because it's a summary of the twenty
five thousand dollar book okay
and there you go I met my book is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure I'm very very proud of that so
I do have a little bit of credibility on
the subject of thyroid
yes you do Dr Wallach for sure
um so real quick because we're coming up
on the holidays Dr Wallach and ham is
a very common food to have with a
Christmas dinner special like the Honey
Baked spiral cut hams
what is your response to
um the typical cured ham that's Honey
Baked
okay well any any of these types of
meats should be excluded okay
um they have chemicals in them ham bacon
bologna salami hot dogs pastrami
pepperoni jerky corned beef spam all
those things gotta go
um because they have chemicals in them
and then there's many religions that
avoid pork also okay we made religions
that avoid pork
um including many Arab religions Jewish
religions and so forth and so
um
I I don't recommend pork in any way
shape or form I like um
leg of lamb lamb chops if you want an
exotic dish meat go for lamb when that
Guy brought me those 50 dead Lambs I saw
right away they didn't have any
infections or anything like that so I
just butchered them and put them in my
freezer I was a student starving to
death so to get 50 Lambs boy that was
cool okay but you know then I found out
that they all they all died of
hypothermia which was good because you
know there was no nothing that could be
transferred to me or my family and so
that fed us for six months okay so we
got a win-win-win situation out of that
one
well if anybody has any good recipes for
leg of lamb please go to askdoc live
click on contact me and share the recipe
for Legoland
let's go to the next town that's up Dr
Wallach and Steve go ahead and unmute
yourself and then we have another hand
up as well let's try to get them both in
Dr Wallach we got nine minutes
hi Dr Wallach I have a friend that has
just shared that she's just completed uh
IV treatments for Lyme disease and other
infections she said her blood test
numbers don't show Improvement uh
symptoms were manageable however she's
recently developed symptoms to a level
that indicates there's probably a
flare-up of the infection so her plane
levels have been increasing and uh so
she's wondering what might be the best
thing for her she's looking for options
right now okay do you have any knowledge
of her weight
uh I'd say she's probably about maybe
120 pounds oh okay all right she's get
rid of all the bad foods get rid of all
the inflammation and maximize absorption
no fried foods no processed means no
oils no glutens no wheat bun around
those so buckwheat no sugar no
carbonated drinks uh then I want her at
120 pounds I wanted to have one healthy
brain and heart pack per month the half
of those everything twice a day I want
her to
I get the collagen peptides one bottle a
month so she can take three twice excuse
me College of peptides okay yeah that's
so she'll need two cancers of that the
scoop other morning drink two other
evening drink she needs MSM uh one
bottle a month take three breakfast
three at dinner time and that's going to
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between vertebrae bone
makes bone itself and that includes the
skin all these things the MSM the
collagen peptides also help rebuild the
skin okay Lyme disease is very very big
in the skin in the intestines and so
forth and then also getting rid of the
cow getting rid of the glucogel
um she's in that glucose the collagen
peptides got to get rid of the
um
uh
let's see here oh you've got you got to
get rid of all the stuff that uh comes
from uh gluten there you go gluten gotta
get rid of gluten no wheat by Ryan oats
and no
um none of the other stuff with the uh
like buckwheat got to get rid of that
and then again at 120 pounds I wanted to
have that one hell of Brandon heart pack
uh one uh MSM
um one or two doses of the collagen
peptides but I do want her to have our
colloidal silver I want her to have our
colloidal silver our colloidal silver
okay uh let me get the right bottle here
here we go our collateral silver so you
can put two droppers full under her
tongue three minutes before bed 30
minutes before each meal and then she
can put it on some cotton that she has
and these Lyme disease lesions on her
lips or her face her back or anything
like that she can put put it directly on
them and this has no alcohol in and it
won't burn even if the wounds are open
there's no alcohol in there it won't
burn and it will kill every bug you can
think of including the Lyme disease bugs
wow
well thank you very much appreciate that
Dr Waller okay
all right thank you Steve and I want to
just add something in there with the
colloidal silver
um with kids and grandkids coming home
with eye infections and styes and all
types of things that colloidal silver
drops can be dropped right into the eye
and that works better than any
antibiotic ointment I've ever tried Dr
Wallach with any of the kids it kills
all the bugs now you say it was used as
an antibiotic for thousands of years
yeah it's absolutely incredible and I
just want to add I want to share one
thing two things so Tammy says that
since taking the 90 essential nutrients
and efas she no longer has to use lotion
like she used to either and Christy I
love this one Dr Wallach she says after
being on an assortment of heavy duty
pain pills antidepressants for 25 years
and seeing 10 different Specialists with
10 different opinions I got fed up a
year and a half ago I started with docs
protocol and have been pain-free and my
health is wonderful I'm 72. take no
prescriptions she says but all of my
friends have medical problems and ignore
me and Christy just keep being that
example
of what they could have and eventually
they're gonna get tired and fed up also
and I you know for for my group
as I'm looking at at people and they're
sharing all of their things on Facebook
as ever all the health concerns that
they've got going on I'll send them a
little message say hey if you're
interested in something different just
let me know
I know where you are I've been there and
I love where I am now because I no
longer have to deal with whatever it is
the condition that you can relate to
them on always keep it honest with all
you do and it does return with good
results
so just wanted to share that and
encourage you Christy and thank you
Tammy for for sharing your testimonial
on that as well Lawrence
go ahead and unmute yourself let's get
your question in here as well
oh thanks uh hey Doc Wallach I always
enjoyed listening to you when you're on
Coast to Coast I try to listen to you uh
whenever you're you're a guest uh on
George Noory show I got a good show a
couple days ago yeah I I know I was
there listening to you hey I got a
question for you on fertility uh my wife
and I were trying to conceive and my
wife has less eggs than she did when she
in her younger years we're going through
IVF uh therapy now uh we're in that
program do you have any recommendations
uh on what could be done in that area
yes
um well both of you need to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody around notes no buckwheat
all that kind of stuff
and then uh per 100 pounds of body
weight one healthy brain and heart pack
per month
um uh also one bottle of the MSM uh all
right and uh let's see here uh the
Beyond
osteofx uh scuba that twice a day
vitamin D3 three of those twice a day
and then I want you to have
our Zara test three of those twice as
two bottles a month gives your sertoli
cells uh and your testicles what it
needs to make testosterone you do need
the eggs to be able to make the
testosterone because testosterone is 95
by weight uh cholesterol and then your
wife needs to be taking the xerofem she
could take three of those twice a day
they'll give her ovaries what they need
to make estrogen and progesterone which
again is 95
cholesterol so she needs the eggs no
statin drugs
that kind of stuff and that's kind of
the direction I would go you know make
sure that all the equipment's working
um and um stay away from the bad stuff
to maximize absorption relieve
inflammation
and as long as she's cycling
okay how old is she
she's 39. oh yeah she should be no
problem okay should be no problem
okay keep in touch and uh let us know
when congratulations are due thanks Doc
take care happy holidays
all right thank you Lawrence and best
wishes to you and your wife on that I
feel success coming so Dr Wallach we are
at the end of our two hours once again I
just want to remind everybody that yes
we will be here next Friday
and the next Friday
as we share more information
that is empowering
and bringing hope and light and
encouragement to not just you but your
communities and your world that is our
goal and as people who took the time
invested time into finding out more
about what Dr Wallach recommends in his
research we encourage you to share it
thank you for investing this time into
yourself and your community and I just
want to thank my co-hosts Heather Bowen
Dr Judy Reynolds Ruth Ellen Sanchez who
are on with me today they help me keep
this program rolling and a safe place
for everybody as we are a resource we if
you are with the youngevity business as
one of our Associates we want to make
sure that you can safely invite your
clients your family your friends here
without having any fear
of somebody else
trying to help your customers we are
here to help everybody but make sure
that they get back with the person that
invited them to this program I know
that's something Dr Wallach you set up
this company as a direct sells yes I'm
proud to say we are a network marketing
company because when we Network
together
we are building each other up we are
building our communities we are working
together with a common goal
in restoring health throughout the world
so Dr Wallach thank you so much for
starting this company and and seeing
how beneficial your research
really is well thank you so much Rebecca
and of course we knew we had to build an
army and this is the way to do it and so
I cannot thank you enough for being one
of the great Generals in our army and um
again uh it's one of those things I want
to remind everybody about The
Reawakening of that CD
um dial MD for murder oh you're going to
get some good stuff in that one dial MD
for murder it is really I mean you and I
have listened to it a couple of times
again and it is so full of good stuff
you can add many healthful years to your
life dial MD for murder
dial MD for murder and you can find that
at d r j Wallick
dot com there you will find all of Dr
wallach's Publications you can also go
to
askdocklive.com we have some of his most
popular Publications that are listed on
our website and again
if you want more information and you
were not referred by anybody's specific
feel free to use the contact us on our
website to get in contact with a
certified holistic health coach that
will be on this journey with you in
making sure that you get the products
and only the products that are right fit
for you we're all about helping people
find Better Health within their budget
we have so many different options and I
appreciate Dr Wallach for that
that we can take and customize a
protocol just for you within your budget
and also if you're interested in joining
me on the keto journey I have
30 pounds that I want to go till I hit
my goal weight I am going to be doing
that I know Heather Bowen who is one of
my co-hosts and Ruth Ellen Sanchez they
are both going to be supporting me in
this as well we have a Facebook group
where we are going to be sharing
information
and if you're on Facebook look for keto
90 together
k-e-t-o-90 Kickstart which is also
together so if you're on Facebook look
for that keto 90 Kickstart and look for
us
we have a page askdoc live page Dr
Wallach also has Wellness Publications
page and the critical Health news who is
kind of like
the big one
um that we have stemmed from within our
group
critical Health news has a web Facebook
page but make sure you look for critical
health
someone got critical Health news before
we did we're trying to figure out who
that was because we are
copyrighted as critical Health news so
make sure that you follow us on critical
Health on Facebook as well and of course
YouTube and Rumble and truth and
Instagram
we are going social folks meeting people
where they're at to make sure that they
also are getting the information that
they need not just to survive but
actually thrive
again my name is Becca Dukes
bye for now
bye-bye and thank you thank you
everybody thank you team bye-bye
thank you Dr Wallach and yes thank you
team and everybody here live with us
thank you for joining us bye for now see
you next week